me I don't give a [ __ ] it's the Lord's
Day [ __ ] we'll kick it up old
school today little sad the bloody just
to get the party started
oh [ __ ] please got beside this or
whatever [ __ ] you got that shit's over
tonight
here we go you're going Joey's [ __ ]
two in one day I can't take it we don't
[ __ ] around here the church we mean
business
[Music]
uncle Joey bronchitis freak because we
don't let the [ __ ] germs even get in
there
[Music]
study naturally l85 periscopes a week
every week it's robbery flew you back on
the resupply by yourself on your belly
it's a new home and every morning from
90 I wake up in salute on [ __ ] Flag
[Music]
LUMS overrated baby boy specially comes
from the Hoodoo lounge a little Sabbath
bloody on a [ __ ] Lord's Day
as a reminder here at the Sugar Shack
that we ain't [ __ ] around my balls
are tip-top Magoo and I hope yours
aren't too because we're going deep deep
deep tonight
[Music]
that's the only get out of Luke you can
lick my nutsack that's how precise juice
say keeping the low [ __ ] to talk truck
with CBS woman named they got nut middle
they put like a technician you gotta get
fixed then the fix is [ __ ] you don't
saying they go around the 2010 here we
go here we go
[Music]
you need a couple
29 years all you look like a 50 year old
boy
I saw your balls
that's what's happening on the [ __ ]
Lord's Day [ __ ] Sunday April
8th
we'll go and come in to the next couple
Joey here we're going deep deep deep
into the hemisphere life
please got drunk at the Mobius the next
day applause Joey don't make me [ __ ]
stab me all alone
this is tremendous this quad recover
whenever you're sick whenever it's got a
little bit of THC in it but let me tell
you something you take one of these when
you're feeling a little box a little
dizzy
maybe you got a call maybe get the
beginnings of the flu wait better than
the [ __ ] thing who told you that your
uncle Joey coach look at this oh and
even taste anything smells like cough
medicine look at the body of Christ
compels you tastes that taste that you
probably I thought the lick you leave me
water with white being a half of
fruitcake look at his face although
we'll see you wouldn't be sick come on
you'll be at some [ __ ] punk range
look at that [ __ ] clubs [ __ ] ugly
dogs [ __ ] make a believe you're like
here we go that's the beginning of the
treatment see
and then we got a TKO and you mix it
that's what gets the whole patois going
you understand me
listen you asking me where I study then
I go to the Dominican Republic no can I
go to Yale no I went to the [ __ ]
school of hard knocks Street medicine
you understand me how to take care
yourself yes they do yes they do cos I'm
alive and that's what proves it
then you got a cushy oh my god I need a
half of that and that's why as lights
out I read understand me
were you looking at it 400 milligrams on
the Lord's Day it's good for you
we'll give you a little mule we get the
recite is going look at you you're a new
man already I can see the colors in your
cheeks already these [ __ ] don't
know now when I was out there living
under a [ __ ] tunnel
I had Street Medicine I didn't eat for
[ __ ] years
I even got teeth back how they do that
cuz I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's how [ __ ] anyway let's
drink some water did you always have to
hydrate when you're doing the [ __ ] th
seeing the particles and whatnot you
ready for a little punk this will help
you breathe
[Music]
tremendous
so the feel you got do a little pocket
trust you have to do a little pocket you
gotta take a pun
how the [ __ ] do you get sick we haven't
done a bondage since last Sunday you
smoked with other people when did you
get the smoke more [ __ ] foreigners
sim saying that's why you buy your
business via [ __ ] oh you're right the
psychiatrist called your [ __ ] coward
I'm trying to help you out here how much
Markey he'd be a coward for me this is
goofy just open up the [ __ ] lungs you
don't know what you're talking about
I've lived it I've lived it I've seen it
how the [ __ ] does a guy like you get
bronchitis every 90 [ __ ] days you
don't even smoke on your own
unbelievable people
it was sick 90 days ago this [ __ ]
they're the same [ __ ] 19 days ago we
male come on leave me the [ __ ] alone all
right
you're gonna be a half a [ __ ] about
everything leave me the [ __ ] alone I can
hold the [ __ ] two hours and have to
be able to have a fight again
[Music]
telling is goofy of me not your [ __ ]
lungs I'm not quite something you didn't
try nothing you smoke one of my Lukey a
[ __ ] joint by yourself
I've seen you [ __ ] smoke you think
everything's a [ __ ] joke here Tony as
a man remember the last time you had it
you took a little pong that you were
fine this is what happens you have to
[ __ ] and expand your [ __ ] horizons
that's what you get the smoke come on
[ __ ] foreigners right you're gonna
have to get a bong start next week and
do a bong and every [ __ ] morning at
nine o'clock
that's party a new job now you just got
new jobs attitude but being a half a [ __ ]
blew the [ __ ] little pond and watch
you coiffures turn red tomorrow you'll
be a whole new [ __ ] man they don't
know what bronchitis there's nothing
left you understand me tell these
[ __ ] this kid something will you but
then he'll go on Yelp and believe
[ __ ] strangers unbelievable they use
the today if we don't get [ __ ] in the
ass by Isis is because of these [ __ ]
people
it's because of these poor souls 35 and
under you [ __ ] lost
unbelievable unbelievable
you see if billy goat is like what the
[ __ ] that that billy goat
do they still be around and here I'm
living like a fruitcake and I can't put
it together can you believe this [ __ ]
then you ask yourself why why the [ __ ]
does your waiting for a bus you want to
get on it but you really know cuz you
hope it never comes [ __ ] I'm saying
always remember if you're gonna wait for
that bus is what you got to do with that
[ __ ] bus you got to stretch your
horizons you gotta be an animal on a
[ __ ] Sunday
cuz the rest of the week will be tip-top
Magoo if you're a [ __ ] atom want a
[ __ ] Sunday but Joey what's with the
[ __ ] bomb is let's do a bong is is
leave [ __ ]
[Music]
let's get down [ __ ] to the
ground here we had a great week sadly at
the Ice House a little working out with
uncle Joey this few tickets left and
then you got yourself oh [ __ ]
you got yourself Columbus Ohio for 420
will I be Neil edibles on stage on 4/20
yes I will
so if you're coming to the show get
ready to go deep because Uncle Joe is
[ __ ] around here oh yeah oh yeah here
we go a little something from the a rat
he's half Russian who knows I don't give
a [ __ ] every time he gives me something
solid over that son seller will say
hello to [ __ ] what's-her-name
Sofia with the blue hair tell uncle Joey
sent you and she'll hook you up with a
[ __ ] polygraph
[Music]
look at that the Banga comes out at the
end the [ __ ] whatever sunrise by
Black Sabbath that's how you know you're
in tune with the [ __ ] universe you
understand me you're sitting at a non on
TV you got a little baseball hopefully
make oh [ __ ]
a little snowblind and hopefully Mick
Turturro is [ __ ] do it up a Yank you
[ __ ] gangs getting ready for the
Boston Red Sox this week so Nick's doing
jumping jacks he's yelling at his wife
the cats getting kicked it don't matter
over there oh [ __ ]
was the other canister with death
look at this [ __ ] thing look at that
right from the [ __ ] corners of your
mind in the stamping that's how you
[ __ ] like it that's how you're
gonna get it you came to the shows and
Albuquerque I love you you were great
audiences
[Music]
and I love your mother [ __ ] down
there it's a great place the green chile
was tremendous I don't even know what to
tell you mother [ __ ] no boy in
Albuquerque if it wasn't for my warrants
had moved out I don't know if I got a
warrant cover you but you never know I
used to go there years ago in the late
night these noodles like a flux donor
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ] so that's sitting that's
debt youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz it's
the place to be understand me I don't
want to hear no [ __ ] stories already
tonight it's gonna be a big week for 24
you [ __ ] pot whatever's is in ten
days you better be in training me I'm
always in training I smoke weed on the
water I don't give a [ __ ] Jackie I got
one of those baggies like they put over
your head [ __ ] for narcos little
little [ __ ] not nutkum pump in it
even on the wall I'm getting [ __ ]
high I don't give a [ __ ] Jackie I smoke
weed and a bubble bath
but anyway youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz 10 minutes and we'll get you off
the [ __ ] right foot for the week you
understand me
poorly looking to be a smokin he's only
drinking [ __ ] dayquil
believe in the [ __ ] height the whole
kit really do every 90 days got [ __ ]
time
that bronchitis ninety days ago yes you
did is we had this conversation
right before fall and got the boot you
[ __ ] it right before you gave it a
groove it's all WLAN do ten minutes
youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz you bad
[ __ ] stay black